[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
remember red raven the entry level red
camera with their most competitive price
i made a video about it before it even
came out walking me through it showing
you around it it was pretty awesome but
then it disappeared it stopped being
sold if you went to red site over the
past couple of months you noticed it
wasn't there it wasn't an option to buy
because they weren't selling them but
now it is back but with an interesting
twist so this video is to announce that
the red raven will be going back on sale
as a camera kit through apple.com
exclusively and available to demo in
certain apple stores what that's a
pretty big move from red a company
that's been making a lot of pretty big
moves lately so the raven kit will be
alongside all the other high visibility
products that apple sells on their
website you probably already knew they
sell first party accessories but
apple.com sells third-party accessories
as well this is joining those so what
exactly is in the raven kit you get the
red raven brain a 4.7 inch touchscreen
lcd monitor possibly my favorite piece
of video gear of all time the sigma 18
to 35 f 1.8 this outrigger handle reds
v-lock io expander module two v-mount
idx batteries and their charger 120 gig
mini mag ssd a gtech mini mag reader and
this can all fit into a heavy duty case
by nanook that's in the kit too plus a
copy of final cut pro 10 and the full
control app for ios the raven camera kit
version so you can kind of look at it as
like a one-stop shop for all things
needed to get this camera off the ground
and running you're ready to get shooting
and this isn't for like a beginner video
maker obviously this is for someone
who's been making video for a while but
wants to take that next step up into the
red raw world above 4k i've already
talked about what these cameras are
capable of in the past in case you've
forgotten i'll leave some links below
but the bottom line here is red cameras
are known for their image quality and
the red raven is no exception with the
red you get the brain of course and then
you add modules you want based on how
you're going to be shooting and of
course you can add more modules to this
kit at any time and then once you get
shooting you get the super realistic
image the awesome color science the high
resolution the huge dynamic range
everything you should get from a cinema
camera and then of course all the
benefits of raw video have i ever have i
ever talked to you guys through raw
video like what it really means in
photography a raw photo versus a jpeg is
a pretty big deal a jpeg is already
processed has all the color and
information baked in compressed ready to
go but if you want to edit any of it you
can push it a little bit but the quality
will start to fall apart pretty quickly
with any major editing so raw photos
keep all the sensor information
unprocessed so the files are bigger but
if you want to make any edits to color
temperature iso contrast sharpness you
can do so without losing much of any
quality that's the super simplified
version so with video pretty much any
camera from your smartphone to a dslr to
a camcorder the videos they record are
like the jpegs all the color information
and everything is baked into a video
codec so prores video is sort of the
equivalent of jpeg for photos but red
cameras are one of the few that can
shoot raw video which means things like
color temperature and iso etc are just
meta data and there are things that can
be changed after the fact without much
of any difference in quality that is the
number one reason i switched to red
cameras a couple years ago when i first
tried the scarlet for a couple days for
the glory that is raw video so when i'm
running and gunning i'm shooting as well
as i can but i'm not worrying too much
about the perfect exposure or perfect
color temperature etc you do want to get
it right in camera but i'm more paying
attention to things like framing and
camera movement and other more creative
things that you can't change later so i
get it pretty close to correct usually
but then here's the kicker you bring the
raw r3d files into final cut pro and
there's a final cut pro plugin on red
site once you grab and install that
final cut pro can not only see the red
footage but it can see and change all
the metadata just like editing raw
photos there's there's literally a color
temperature slider here in final cut pro
thanks to that plugin i swear some of
the before and after frames for my
videos would probably shock you it's not
quite magic but it's about as close as
it gets in my world and then this raven
over here can shoot both red code raw
and prores simultaneously so if you're
on a shoot and you don't actually need
that raw footage you don't have to use
it so yeah raven is a great first raw
video tool i think for again people who
are just stepping into the world of
beyond 4k it's a 4.5 k sensor and people
who just want that flexibility of having
a modular camera system it's not really
for beginners like i said but it's kind
of interesting that it'll be in apple
stores and a lot of people will be
seeing this for the first time and it's
kind of in a place where people are are
first getting their feet wet from
rigging your camera to be a video camera
to an actual full-fledged cine camera
with all the modularity that comes with
that it's really interesting so that's
red raven it's back now you know maybe
you'll see an apple store near you
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]